you've I think a tweeted something about
ideas coming out from sometimes feeling
about coming from outside of you
sometimes so you mentioned as you
meditate
you know you notice these ideas come in
so
thoughts ideas how did that connect
consciousness
so the thing I was responding to that
you wrote
um
I think I was partly
picking up on the part of you that would
really get a lot out of a Meditation
Retreat that was my way of beginning
that conversation
um that experience you had of a thought
coming from somewhere else
when you spend an extended period of
time paying close attention to your
moment-to-moment experience that's how
all of your thoughts
appear to you
and it's really beautiful because you're
letting go just through the practice of
meditation meditation you're quieting
down your
um default mode Network and without
necessarily
um intellectually thinking yourself out
of free will it it naturally kind of
drops away and so
when you're under the spell of this
illusion that you are the author of your
thoughts and your conscious experience
is driving all of your behavior and
there's this eye that stands
somewhere near your brain but is not
your brain that stands free of the
physical world is is the thing
generating the thoughts
um
when you're meditating
that quiets down and can kind of quiet
down completely so that your experience
is just of the next thing arising in
your conscious awareness but it's the
source of that is still this brain what
you realize is the source of it is not
your conscious experience and that's the
important insight
and that's the insight and so there are
many insights you can have in meditation
that align with the science which is
what's really fascinating because it
doesn't have to be that way like I can
imagine finding a meditation to be
extremely useful and helping me with
anxiety and all the rest and having all
kinds of insights that turn out to not
be true
but the interesting thing is that these
insights actually turn out to be true
um and so that that is one of them is
the
when you're just watching what your
conscious experience actually is you
realize that it's not doing all the
things you usually feel like it's doing
and so the thoughts really just arise
in much the same way that a sound or a
sight or a feeling
um you know maybe your leg starts to
hurt you when you're just watching
Moment by Moment by moment pain arises
the bird chirping arises
a thought arises a feeling arises
you're just kind of watching watching it
all unfold and there's something really
beautiful about that
yeah it's
the the the perspective you could take
on is there's a connectedness to the
entirety of the universe like to Nature
in general and that there's something so
beautiful about Consciousness about the
fact that
it's not just a dead Universe with atoms
doing their thing that
at least in this one instance there is a
felt experience of the universe
of the University it's not even I'm part
of the universe yeah I'm there's a right
here in this little point in space and
time there is an experience of the
universe but it's still interesting to
think about where those ideas
if those ideas are solely a construction
of the brain or is there some kind of
mechanism of joint collective
intelligence of humans as social
organisms where that those like
like how much of it is me training my
neural network and the ideas of tens of
thousands of other people and how much
is it myself talking like in terms of
psychic phenomena and you're talking in
terms of just absorbing the information
of the past and education and
well um just kind of our Collective
human project that gets in throughout
our lives I don't know much about
psychic phenomena but I also want to be
open-minded in the way we speak about
collective intelligence because it's
very easy to simplify to it's a neural
network trained on knowledge developed
over generations and so on it it does
feel like intelligence is stored in some
kind of distributed fashion
across humans like if you take one out
I think that intelligence quickly goes
down
I don't know how quickly it goes down if
you just take one out and depends on
which one I think I half agree and half
disagree with what you're saying but
yeah I mean the other thing you notice
when you spend a lot of time in
meditation and when you spend a lot of
time kind of shaking up the these
intuitions that I think get in the way
of of clearly
okay
thinking about what Consciousness is
um
is that we are these systems in nature
that are not at all isolated and there
are the obvious ways like if I just stop
drinking water you know
that's going to change the system very
drastically right so there's just you
know the the energy consumption but the
fact that we exchange ideas is
um we
part of who I am is everyone I've
interacted with and of course the people
I interact more with have sculpted me
more but we our brains are sculpted
through our interactions with each other
as well
yes but I wonder if it's a more correct
and useful perspective to take
that those interactions are the
organisms
like you're saying you're still making
the brain the primary
there could be like
uh that the brain is what it is because
of the social interactions and the
social interactions are the living
organism like I that that's a weird
perspective because it's I don't I don't
actually think it's one or the other
they're both yeah they're both both
living yeah it's like cats and dogs
yeah I mean it's a little bit like you
know I I have two children and a lot of
people with two children will stay like
when when you're preparing to have the
second one and soon after you've had the
second one that having two is kind of
like having three because you are
um nourishing and protecting and
overseeing each individual life but then
there's the sibling relationship which
is almost another
thing yeah it's weird